Australia's wild dog the dingo is on the
prowl
today it hunts alone a sign the dingo is
probably on the lookout for small thing
but it senses a larger opportunity a
baby kangaroos called a Joey makes an
excellent target it's too big for his
mother to carry if she has to run away
the dingo slinks forward while the Joey
unaware keeps busy grooming himself his
mother senses a nearby predator but it's
not the dingo her attention is fixed on
the wedge tailed eagle flying above his
mother calls Joey to her side
neither one sees the dingo approaching
through the brush for a moment a young
male freezes
his panic feeds contagious the mother
and her Joey make their getaway to the
dingo bursts after the ruse the dingoes
no slouch when it comes to ski but the
ruse reached 35 miles per hour
dingoes have better luck hunting in
packs when they're after large kangaroos
it's back to searching for prey that's
not so big and not so fast